let's shutter those windows remove our
blindfolds and take a good look at the
film that caused so much hype over the
2018 holiday season this is the untold
truth of Byrd box spoilers ahead while
it may have felt like someone simply
took the happening in a quiet place and
smoosh them together into a new film
called Byrd box the director Susan beer
has confirmed that wasn't the case at
all
she told polygon no no no we were
shooting in April 2018 and we had heard
of a quiet place that we were almost
finished editing when it came out the
film is actually based on a novel of the
same name published by Josh mal Amman in
2014 one major difference between the
novel and the film is the ending in the
book when Mallory boy and girl or Reese
a sanctuary at the end of the river it
doesn't turn out to be quite the
paradise they were expecting considering
the other survivors have purposefully
blinded themselves for protection this
change from a deflated discouraging end
to a slightly more hopeful finale was
explained by director beer who pointed
out I'm not particularly interested for
the audience to leave from the cinema or
their own screen with a kind of
completely bleak point-of-view one of
the other larger deviations from the
original text came in the form of some
significant changes to a handful of the
characters in the first act of the film
Mallory's sister Jessica is quickly
whisked away after she sees a creature
while driving Mallory home in the book
though she survives along with her
sister for a few months before falling
victim to the monsters Mallory's love
interest Tom was also altered rather
than surviving in the house and going on
to raise boy and girl with Mallory he
falls victim to Gary while she is busy
delivering her baby and then there's
Douglas while he ended up being a
crucial part of the movie his character
was entirely non-existent in the book
although the novel's character dharma
seems to closely fit that role from
christian bale's shocking transformation
for the Machinists to call him first
preparation for The King's Speech the
way an actor preps for a role can be
fascinating and third box is no
exception
bollocky did some intense research
before shooting up blindfold scenes
according to Meera beer revealed that
Bullock spent time with a blind man who
specializes in teaching other blind
people to navigate at one point bugs
commitment hurt her on set when her
blindfold
into a collision with a camera that drew
blood well she may have been committed
to the role regardless of our own safety
Bullock's passion for authenticity did
give way when it came to the safety of
others
she had the blindfold reduced to a
single layer of thickness whenever she
had to carry her on-screen kids through
a scene there's always an element of me
adhered to those kids to make sure that
I knew where they were I needed to
return them to their parents at the end
of the day that was Michael Bullock
trained to be able to move without
sighted bird bugs but she purposefully
didn't prepare for another aspect of a
character's journey the first time she
stepped into the boat that takes her and
the kids down the river
she had no boating experience Bullock
considered the story carefully and
decided to use her aquatic ignorance in
her favor
insisting that the river scenes be
filmed in chronological order - that's
her rowing could look better as the
movie progressed precisely as it would
look for the equally inexperienced
Mallory at the end of bird boxes first
week the Netflix Twitter account posted
a tweet boasting that the movie had
already been watched by an impressive 45
million accounts giving it the best
first seven days ever for a Netflix film
while that's a milestone worth
celebrating many news outlets were quick
to criticize her figure as less
meaningful than it seemed
Netflix's tight control of its
viewership numbers has made any stat
shared by the company less trustworthy
than the rating system used for cable
and the broadcast networks did 45
million people really stream bird box in
his first week maybe not but the film's
versed certainly makes it easy to
believe that everyone and their mother
was watching this thing over the 2018
holiday break check out one of our
newest videos right here Plus even more
looper videos about your favorite movies
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]